هديه العام الجديد من اداره نادي النصر
السعودي الى جماهير فريقها وللكره
السعوديه تمثلت بالتوقيع من النجم
البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو بعد اشهر من
الاحاديث التي دارت حول الصفقه النصر
السعودي دمر رونالدو لمده موسمين ونصف حيث
يستمر النجم البرتغالي المخضرم حتى نهايه
موسم 2025 وفي اول تعليق له على الصفقه
اكد النجم البرتغالي تشوقه لخوض التجربه
الجديده والانضمام لفريقه الجديد لمساعدته
على تحقيق المزيد من النجاح فيما كان رئيس
المجلس اداره النصر نار رونالدو مثال اعلى
لجميع رياضيين وسيمضي قدما في تحقيق
المزيد من النجاحات السعوديه والاجيال
القادمه يعد النجم البرتغالي كريستيانو
رونالدو ثاني لاعب برتغالي في تاريخ نادي
النصر السعودي حيث سبقه لذلك اللاعب
البرتغالي في موسم 2004 رونالدو لفريق
النصر بعد ثلاث الزيارات الى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه حيث سبق له التواجد فيها
عام 2008 لاول مره وعام 2019 مرتين الكثير
من الاشاعات سبق التوقيعه رونالدو للنصر
منها رفض لذلك وتوقيع لنادي ريال مدريد
لنصف موسم ثم الاعتزال الا ان كل ذلك لم
يكن الى مجرد تكهنات انتهت بوصول الى
الرياض اللعب مع احد اعرق الانديه
السعوديه كريستيانو رونالدو سيكون على
موعد قريب مع لقاء غريمه التنافسي اليمنى
لميسي حين يلتقي نجوم نادي النصر والهلال
مع نادي باريس سان جيرمان فرنسي في ال 19
من يناير المقبل
[موسيقى]
النصر غير الفطور
اتخلى اللاعب العالميه المخضرم كريستيانو
رونالدو في صفقه تاريخيه الى الدوري
السعودي تفاصيل او في حول هذه الصفقه
لنادي النصر
في العالم اعلنت صفقه انتقال رونالدو
رسميا الى نادي النصر وبعدها بخمس ساعات
همم النادي النصر اتطر الى انه يعلن
الصقاب بطريقه غير معتاده انه نحن دائما
كنا بنشوف في الصفقات الانديه السعوديه
الانديه الاوروبيه لانه الصفقه عن طريق
فيديو مبتكر او بطريقه احترافيه جذابه
يعني بس الخبر طلعته العربيه وخلت وكاله
الانباء كلها تنقل الخبر على العربيه انه
اجبر نادي النصر انه خلاص بعد خمس ساعات
انا لازم عليها صفقه لانه خلاص الخبر
انتشر طبعا اكيد الخبر طالع من العربيه
المصدر همم
الرياضه بس عبد الملك مين الكاس بالاكبر
في هذه الصفقه اليوم من سيستفيد اكثر
بانضمام رونالدو الى نادي النصر قصر ام
رونالدو
النصر بالنسبه لي بنتكلم من شقين الشق
الاول الحاجات اللي شفناها مباشره مثلا
بعد خبر بعد انفرد خبر بعد خبر العربيه
والانفراد متجر نادي النصر
امتلى بال بالمحبين النادي النصر اشتراء
قمصان رونالدو وكتبوا رقم 7 خلال 24 ساعه
حقك ايرادات ما يعادل اثنين مليون ريال
سعودي حسب التقارير الصحفيه السعوديه
الجانب الاخر هيكون في اقبال كبير على بث
التلفزيون من قبل القنوات عالميه من شرق
اسيا من امريكا الجنوبيه امريكا الشماليه
برده القنوات البرتغاليه على الطالب حسب
مصادرنا حطالب بالحصول على الحقوق البث
باعتباره انه كريستيانو رونالدو النجم همم
النجم البرتغالي يعني
في كثير ناس على مواقع التواصل اعلن
واعلانيه
ونصف النصر كانوا هلاليين او من نوادي
ثاني صحيح
في 2012 في ديسمبر في السنه الماضيه يعني
في ديسمبر
انه رونالدو صاحب اعلى قيمه السوقيه في
2022 متفوق على نجمه التنس ويليامز على
هاملتون بطل العالم في الفاره في فورمولا
1 على ليبرون جيمس نجم السله على ليونيل
ميسي بطل كاس العالم فاكيد هو قيمه عاليه
جدا جدا شفنا النجاحاته الاقتصاديه
والرياضيه مع يوفنتوس مع مانشستر يونايتد
مع ريال مدريد
[موسيقى]